YOU GET UP?
UP. YEAH. YOU
ALL RIGHT LAWYER.
LAWYER,
LAWYER.
WE HAVE A WARRANT FOR YOUR
ARREST. YOU CAN GET A LAWYER
YOU'RE HOLDING CELL
FLOYD WILLIAMS DURING YOU ARE
UNDER ARREST FOR INSIDER
TRADING AND SECURITIES
FRAUD. YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO EXERCISE
THAT, RIGHT?
THAT WAS KELLY. AUCOIN WHO
PLAYS DOLLAR BILL
STERN, A
CUTTHROAT WALL STREET TRADER
ON ONE OF MY FAVORITE SHOWS,
THE SHOWTIME DRAMA
BILLIONS
THAT SERIES PLAYS OUT
EVERYTHING. YOU HATE ABOUT NEW
YORK'S WORLD OF FINANCE BRAZEN
CORRUPTION,
UNCHECKED POWER, TOXIC
MASCULINITY, AND VORACIOUS
GREED,
AND NO MATTER WHAT, THIS
UNTOUCHED CLASS OF FINANCIERS.
DOES, THEY ALWAYS SEEM TO COME
OUT ON TOP RARELY?
IS
THERE WRONGDOING MET WITH
CONSEQUENCES,
THE KIND OF CONSEQUENCES THAT
YOU AND I MIGHT FACE,
IT'S JUST ONE.
DEAL. AFTER ANOTHER
BILLIONS WAS INSPIRED BY THE
ACTIONS OF REAL-LIFE
PROSECUTORS OF THE RICH AND
POWERFUL LIKE PREET BHARARA
AND ELIOT SPITZER AND IT'S
OFTEN HARD TO SEPARATE OUT THE
FACT FROM THE FICTION.
REMEMBER?
NOT A SINGLE WALL STREET BANK
BOSS WAS PROSECUTED FOR THEIR
ROLE IN THE 2008, FINANCIAL
CRASH. NOT A ONE AND
AS FOR THE PANDEMIC, OVER THE
SUMMER,
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL
REPORTED THAT THE BIG BANKS
ARE SET FOR BIG PROFITS.
IN FACT U.S. BILLIONAIRES HAVE
SEEN THEIR WEALTH SURGE BY
1.8 TRILLION
DOLLARS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
MEANWHILE, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS HAVE HAD THEIR
PANDEMIC. UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS CUT OFF AND ARE READY
FOR EVICTION,
AND I'M GETTING READY FOR
EVICTION NOTICES AT THEIR
DOORSTEPS. SO IF YOU THINK
BILLIONAIRES ARE OUR ONLY
VILLAINS ON TV SHOWS,
WELL,
YOU'RE NOT PAYING ATTENTION.
I'M JOINED NOW BY THE MAN WHO
PLAYS ON SCREEN. THE CHEAPEST
BILLIONAIRE IN AMERICA
KELLY AUCOIN OR DOLLAR BILL
FROM BILLIONS,
KENNY. THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON THE SHOW TONIGHT.
HOW DID YOU COME TO PLAY THIS
NOW? ALMOST ICONIC.
CHARACTER?
DOLLAR BILL
STERN AND HOW MUCH IS HE YOU?
BECAUSE I BELIEVE YOU
INITIALLY TURNED THE ROLE
DOWN.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE
ICONIC. I'LL TAKE THAT. I'M
GOING TO MAKE SURE MY AGENT
GETS THAT
USES THAT WORD TO DESCRIBE IT
IN THE FUTURE.
I CAME ABOUT IT, LIKE,
EVERYBODY ELSE. I DITION FOR
THE ROLE.
I INITIALLY TURNED IT DOWN
BECAUSE I AUDITIONED FOR A
LARGER ROLE THAT WAS
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE A
RECURRING ROLE IN THE SHOW AND
THEY LIKED WHAT THEY DID, BUT
THEY DIDN'T THINK IT
MATCHED. WHAT THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR FOR THIS OTHER
CHARACTER.
SO THEY ASKED ME TO READ FOR
DOLLAR BILL AND
IT DIDN'T EVEN
AUNTIE IT WAS RECURRING. SO I
THOUGHT IT WAS A ONE-OFF
AND I SAID NO,
AND THEN, OF COURSE, OF THE
WEEKEND, I THOUGHT MORE AND I
WAS THINKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND THE FACT THAT
HE'S GOT A FUNNY NICKNAME, AND
THE FACT THAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE A DESCRIPTION THAT HE'S
THE CHEAPEST MILLIONAIRE IN
AMERICA AND IT JUST STRUCK ME
THAT MAYBE THERE WOULD BE SOME
GROWTH POTENTIAL FOR THE ROLE.
AND THE SMARTEST DECISION I'VE
EVER MADE IN MY CAREER. WAS
THAT FOLLOWING MONDAY EMAIL,
MY AGENTS AND SAY, CAN
I STILL GET IN? AND
I WAS ABLE TO
AND NO, OH, AND I AM.
SO LET'S
TALK. MY WIFE HAS TOLD ME. IF
YOU EVER BRING AN OUNCE OF
THIS GUY INTO THE HOUSE,
YOU'RE OUT MY FRIEND,
SO I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
LOVE MY WIFE MORE.
YO, I LOVE MISBEHAVE
DOLLAR BILL.
YOU'RE ONE WIFE IN REAL LIFE
AS OPPOSED TO YOUR TO
FICTIONAL WIVES ON THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT. LET'S TALK
ABOUT
BILLIONS. THE NEW SEASON IS
CURRENTLY ON SHOWTIME ON
SUNDAY NIGHTS. I WANT TO PLAY
A CLIP FROM SEASON
3 THO HAVE A WATCH.
SO,
YOU'RE LAUGHING, I'M LAUGHING
OUT LOUD.
WHAT SHOULD I WATCH THAT? SO
MANY TIMES IS
BILLIONS KELLY SUPPOSED TO BE
A SHOW
IN WHICH VIEWERS ARE TURNED
OFF
BY THE
UNCHECKED CAPITALISM AND TOXIC
BEHAVIOR THAT THEY SEE ON
SCREEN, THE
1% IS BEHAVING BADLY,
OR ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO BE
TURNED ON? IS IT A GUILTY
PLEASURE TO WANT TO ROOT FOR
ACTS AND WAGS AND DOLLAR
BILL?
I THINK
I'M NOT IN THE
HEADS OF THE CREATORS OF THE
SHOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY SET OUT
TO DO AND WHAT THEY MAY
HAVE
SHIFTED INTO
ATTEMPTING TO DO.
BUT I WILL SAY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS
I APPRECIATE
THAT.
I HAVE MY TAKE ON.
I THINK THE SHOW DOES ASK A
QUESTION
UNDERNEATH EVERYTHING. I THINK
IT ASKS THE QUESTION OR AT
LEAST SUGGEST THE QUESTION.
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S POSSIBLE
TO BE
A DECA BILLIONAIRE.
A BIG BILLY AS THEY SAY.
AS THEY SAY AND TO STILL BE A
GOOD PERSON,
AND THAT IS A QUESTION
IT
ALLOWS THE AUDIENCE TO
ANSWER. IT, DOESN'T I
APPRECIATE THAT. IT DOESN'T
BEAT YOU OVER THE HEAD
WITH MORALIZING. I THINK
THERE ARE BUILT-IN CRITICISMS.
I THINK IT
TRUE
TO WHAT WE KNOW IN THE WORLD
THAT THERE ARE
FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
PERHAPS SATISFYING.
CONSEQUENCES THAT SOME
MISBEHAVING
AGENTS.
MEET. SO YEAH.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY JUST FOR
OUR VIEWERS AT HOME THAT
KELLYO COINED VIEWS ON
BANKERS AND WALL STREET,
TRADERS. AND HEDGE FUNDS IS
VERY DIFFERENT TO DOLLAR BILLS
VIEWS. YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO
THINKS WE SHOULD TAKE
A HARSHER MORE
BERNIE S KLEIN WITH WALL
STREET. IS THAT FAIR?
I WHEN I WAS SAY IS YES,
ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW
FROM DOLLAR BILL.
I
DON'T THINK THAT EVERY
REGULATIONS IS
EVERY REGULATION.
MEANS THAT YOU'RE A SOCIALIST,
EVERY TIME YOU TRY TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS MEANS YOU'RE A
SOCIALIST.
IT
IT DOESN'T
MEAN, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS SIMPLY
BRIDGES AND ROADS. I BELIEVE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND A NEW
WORLD. PERHAPS
MEANS A LITTLE MORE. I DO
THINK THAT PERHAPS SOME SORT
OF GREEN NEW DEAL
COULD TRANSFORM OUR ECONOMY
AND IF YOU ARE
A CAPITALIST AND BELIEVE IN
THE
CAPITALIST SYSTEM, THEN YOU
MUST BELIEVE THAT IT CAN
EVOLVE AND GROW.
AND ACTUALLY WORK FOR PEOPLE,
BUT IT HAS TO HAVE PROTECTIONS
FOR PEOPLE AS WELL.
MUSIC TO MY EARS. I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THE VIEWERS WOULD
AGREE.
SO KELLY JUST
LISTENING TO YOU SPEAK
THEIR YOU FOLLOW POLITICS. YOU
SOUND QUITE POLITICAL
YOURSELF. YOU SOUND LIKE
YOU'RE ON THE LEFT. NOT THE
RIGHT.
YOUR FATHER LES.
AUCOIN WAS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM OREGON. I
BELIEVE HE CAMPAIGNED AGAINST
REAGAN SUPPORT FOR THE CONTRAS
CAMPAIGNED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION'S
YOUR MOTHER SUSAN. WORKED FOR
THE NATIONAL ABORTION,
RIGHTS ACTION LEAGUE. I WONDER
HOW MUCH IMPACT WORLD
YOU'RE BRINGING HAVING PARENTS
LIKE THAT.
YES,
I SUPPOSE PARENTS LIKE THAT
WITH THEIR IMPRESSIVE
RESUMES. HOW MUCH DID THAT
IMPACT YOU?
YOUR UPBRINGING, THE CAUSES
YOU ADVOCATE FOR TODAY HOW
POLITICAL WAS YOUR HOUSEHOLD
GROWING UP?
I WAS VERY POLITICAL AND
MORE
IMPORTANTLY, SPECIFIC. I WOULD
SAY IT WAS AN ACTIVIST.
FIGHTING. THE GOOD FIGHT WAS
NOT A CLICHE, WASN'T SOMETHING
YOU
CRINGED AT. IT WASN'T A CUTE
LITTLE APHORISM. FIGHTING THE
GOOD FIGHT WITH SOMETHING
PEOPLE ACTUALLY SAID IN MY
HOUSEHOLD
AND BELIEVED IT.
THE POLITIC MY DAD WOULD COME
HOME FROM YOU ABOUT THE MX
MISSILE, AND WE WOULD OVER
DINNER BECAUSE HE ALWAYS CAME
HOME FOR DINNER, WHICH WAS I
DON'T KNOW HOW HE DID THAT
WITH A CONGRESSMAN'S SCHEDULE.
SOMETIMES HE WENT BACK TO WORK
AFTERWARDS,
BUT HE WOULD TALK TO US ABOUT
WHAT THE DEBATE WAS AND
HE WOULD LAY THINGS OUT IN A
WAY. THAT WAS SO CLEAR. I
ALWAYS ADMIRED HIM FOR THAT.
HE WAS,
HE WAS A DEMOCRAT AS
HOWARD DEAN WOULD SAY FROM
THE, HE WAS FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE, HE WAS
PROGRESSIVE.
HE ALSO
I WAS WITH SOMEBODY WHO
UNDERSTOOD THAT,
I WOULD GUESS TO SAY, I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY YOU COULD HAVE
HIM ON AS WELL, BUT THAT HE
WAS A HE WAS NOT AN
ANTI-CAPITALIST NECESSARILY,
BUT HE
WANTED A CAPITALISM THAT
ACTUALLY HAD CHECKS.
CAPITALISM. THAT ACTUALLY WAS
NOT UNFETTERED AND
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY WORKED
FOR PEOPLE
AND THE NUCLEAR FREEZE WAS ONE
OF HIS EARLY ISSUES AND I
COULD GO ON.
I'M DEAD. I'M A FANBOY OF MY
DAD.
I HAVE TO SAY,
I'M WHAT ARE THE ISSUES YOU'RE
ADVOCATING FOR ANNOUNCER? WHAT
ARE THE ISSUES THAT YOU FEEL
STRONGLY
ABOUT?
VOTING RIGHTS IS PROBABLY
RIGHT AT THE TOP RIGHT NOW.
HAVE HAD SO MANY ARGUMENTS
WITH PEOPLE WHO
WHO DIDN'T VOTE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF ELECTIONS.
AND WHEN I BECAUSE THEY JUST
COULDN'T GET THEM TO SEE
BEYOND
THE,
TO MY MIND, MISGUIDED NOTION
THAT THE CANDIDATES WERE THE
SAME.
AND I WOULD ALWAYS BRING UP
THE
THE SUPREME COURT AND
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WOULD SAY,
LOOK. I'M NOT A ONE-ISSUE
VOTER AND
MY STANCE WAS ALWAYS, THAT'S
NOT ONE ISSUE. THAT'S ALL THE
ISSUES
AND I SEE WE ARE, WE
ARE NOW
HERE OR WE'RE ON THE VERGE
OF SEEING THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THAT KIND OF TO MY
MIND. LAZY THINKING,
ANYWAY, VOTING RIGHTS.
VOTE, WRITERS.
OUR IDE RS IS A GREAT
ORGANIZATION
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION THAT
SIMPLY HELPS PEOPLE NAVIGATE
VOTER ID LAWS
FAIR FIGHT.
AND
AND ALSO
I'M ON THE BOARD OF AUTISM
RIGHTS AND ACCEPTANCE
ORGANIZATION CALLED CULTURE
CITY. AND WE ADVOCATE FOR THE
RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE IN SPECTRUM WITH
SENSORY NEEDS
BY HELPING THEM PROVIDE ACCESS
TO SPACES THAT ARE USUALLY
OFF-LIMITS TO THEM. AND WE'VE
ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH POLICE
STATIONS,
TRYING TO
TRAIN SOME OF THESE OFFICER
ALL THE OFFICERS. ACTUALLY.
THAT'S OUR GOAL IN THE COUNTRY
TO LEARN
AFTER
BEHAVIORS AND WHAT
IT MIGHT MEAN OTHER THAN JUST
RAW AGGRESSION.
I MEAN
ACTIVISM IS SO IMPORTANT, AS
YOU MENTIONED, JUST A MOMENT
AGO. YOU GREW UP. NOT A
POLITICAL HOUSE OVERACTIVE IS
HOUSEHOLD. YOU THEN BECAME AN
ACTOR. I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOUR
PARENTS MADE OF THAT.
ANOTHER ROLE YOU'RE KNOWN FOR
AS AN ACTOR. IS YOUR ROLE
AS PASTOR, TIM IN
THE SPY DRAMA, THE AMERICANS,
WHICH WAS ON FX ALTHOUGH
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT DOLLAR BILL AND PASS THE
TIP OF THE SAME PERSON. LET'S
WATCH A CLIP OF YOU BEING
CONFRONTED IN THE AMERICANS BY
THE LEAD CHARACTER THE
RUSSIAN SLEEPER AGENT PHILIP
JENNINGS.
I'LL WRITE YOU A CHECK RIGHT
NOW IF YOU WANT, BUT
THAT'S NOT WHY YOU'RE HERE.
NO, IT'S NOT.
I EVERYTHING GONNA BEAT ME UP.
MR. JENNINGS.
FOR
$600
FOR YOUR DAUGHTER, I WOULD DO
ANYTHING FOR MY DAUGHTER.
I WOULD DO ANYTHING
FOR MY DAUGHTER.
THE BEST THING YOU CAN DO FOR
HER, IS FIND A WAY TO DEAL
WITH YOUR ANGER.
KELLY, I LOVE THAT SHOW TO IT
WAS A SHOW ALL ABOUT RUSSIAN
ESPIONAGE AND SLEEPER AGENTS
IN AMERICA AND ITS FINAL TWO
SEASONS AT AROUND THE SAME
TIME, AS
TRUMP SELECTION ACCUSATIONS OF
RUSSIAN, COLLUSION, THE MALAR
INQUIRY DID SOME OF THAT SEEP
INTO THE SHOW. DID YOU FEEL
THE REAL WORLD POLITICS,
THE RUSSIA ANGLE ON
SET?
I DID IT WAS IT WAS NOT.
A SINGLE TIME THAT SOMEONE
MADE THE JOKE ABOUT
PHILIP AND
ELIZABETH FINDING. THIS
MAY BE A
STORYLINE COULD BE
COULD BE
INTRODUCED WHERE THEY FIND
THIS
RUSSIAN HELPING HIM AS AN
ASSET FOR THE NEXT
20 PLUS YEARS.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT
REALLY RESONATED WITH
ME ABOUT THE CHARACTER? WAS,
I REMEMBER A TIME BECAUSE
DOLLAR, BILL
DOLLAR PASTOR PASTOR TIM,
WAS AN ACTIVIST.
SWEET, CARING ACTIVIST.
ACTIVIST POLITICALLY ON THE
LEFT
MAN OF THE CLOTH. AND
THE POSITION OF THE CLOTH, THE
ARGUMENTS, THE POLITICAL
DISCUSSION AROUND
RELIGION, AND PEOPLE OF
RELIGION, HAS BEEN CO-OPTED BY
THE RIGHT AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THIS IS REPRESENTING A TIME
WHEN THAT WASN'T THE CASE
AND MY DAD, A LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT WORKED.
REALLY SUCCESSFULLY WITH A
NUMBER OF
PROGRESSIVE, CHURCHES, BACK IN
THE DAY.
AND I LOVE THE FACT
THAT I TOLD JOE FIELDS AND JOE
WEST,
THE CREATORS OF THE SHOW THAT
THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS.
REALLY DREW ME TO THE ROLE AND
AND THE TRUTH IN THAT, I
THOUGHT
IT SAID IT WAS SPENT, IT
WAS GREAT.
NOW, IT'S SUCH A GREAT ROLE.
WE'RE OUT OF TIMES THAT LIE,
BUT IT'S SUCH A GREAT WHILE. I
URGE EVERYONE TO WATCH THE
AMERICANS AND OF COURSE YOU
CAN CATCH NEW EPISODES OF
BILLIONS EVERY SUNDAY NIGHT ON
SHOWTIME
KELLY. AUCOIN. IT'S BEEN AN
ABSOLUTE PLEASURE. THANK YOU